I'm serious a more perfect union shows
that what unites us as Americans is far
greater than what divides us our story
this morning features two people united
by sacrifice kay Jordan and Michael
Parrish lost their sons in war they have
spent the summer biking across the
country to raise awareness for families
have experienced similar pain Dana
Jacobson met them along their journey of
healing Dana good morning good morning
that cross-country ride that you
mentioned is part of an effort by the
nonprofit legacies alive to support gold
star families those who have lost loved
ones and service to our country the
group gets its message out through
extreme challenges like this one a
cycling trek from San Diego to New York
City with daily rides totaling as much
as 100 miles I think about Austin all
the time he's on my necklace and when
I'm going up hills or I'm having a hard
time I just kiss his dog tags and he
motivates me I think my son almost every
day anyhow but this is just a little bit
more he's got many heals for three
months kay Jordan and Michael Parrish
have battled those hills along with
muddy trails and the desolate open road
they both lost sons in the war on terror
the memories of them are fueling this
solemn journey he loved laughing he
loved making people laugh that's Austin
how about Michael how do you want people
to remember your son his smile
yeah he's quietness it was a real quiet
guy
strangers at the start K and Michael are
now bound by a common goal a
thirty-seven hundred mile cross-country
bike ride to raise awareness for gold
star families and honor all who made the
ultimate sacrifice
it's almost like our kids hearts are in
us and we are riding because you know
they can't live in 2010 just 96 days
into his first deployment in Afghanistan
Kay's son Austin a private first class
in the army was killed by an Afghan
soldier I didn't believe it I didn't
want to believe it I grabbed his picture
in the house and I just fell to the
floor you know lot of denial sets in and
for a year and a half I isolated myself
I didn't want to be around people how
did you get yourself out of that I knew
that's not what Austin wouldn't want me
to do the death of Michael's son is
classified I don't know it was just it
was a nightmare it's still been a
nightmare you know it always been right
there how has this ride helped with that
it's just you could talk talk freely
about you know your kids but it's been a
good journey it's been really healing
and we got to meet a lot of good gold
star families that just want to talk
about their kids connecting with those
families making sure their children
aren't forgotten is central to K and
Michael's mission more motivation has
come from a member of the support team
Chris ring this decorated former Navy
SEAL completed his own challenge two
years ago oh is that personal Jill going
up back when swam the Mississippi River
to honor the fallen
I love being out here as long as I can
because it's like I want to protect them
as much as I can I want them to be
uncomfortable at all he's got his little
ways he going up here there's your water
you need to drink this you know making
sure he just takes care of us there was
no quit in the Mississippi River for him
so there's no quit for us either what
does that meant to you to have each
other on this ride could get you know
you could go to any doctor and
they give you pills they talk to you but
until you talk to somebody that's going
through it that's the best thing you
could do you were total strangers going
into this can you describe what the bond
is like between you now
well we're family not a family we wanted
to be a part of and for the worst reason
we're family
did we lost him our children but without
each other it was we it would be hard to
survive because we get each other we
understand each other
kay and Michael will finish their
challenge ride tomorrow morning in New
York City at Ground Zero and this trip
to New York was actually won Kay had
planned to take with Austin when he got
back from Afghanistan even putting money
in a makeshift coin jar once he got
deployed as she told me she is just
taking him in a different way now oh my
gosh Dana I'm a puddle and I think it's
such a beautiful story it's such a
wonderful tribute but we're all so sorry
they even have to do to make this
journey that's what yeah I think as Kay
said that they're sorry that their
family nobody wants to be a part of this
gold star family but they're the only
ones who really understand each other
which means that I kiss his dog tag
snore and it helps me get it to him I
know beautiful peace be and I know son
and I'm reminder what unites us is
greater than what divides us and I found
like people who they can find comfort
with yeah what a great story thank you
thank you produce that with you that was
Molly Mozilla great job